let's add some more rational expressions
so let's say I have 1 over x squared
minus 9 and to that I'm going to add I'm
going to add 2 over x squared plus 5x
plus 6 so just like we did when we first
learned to add fractions or to add
rational numbers we always have to come
up with a common denominator so once
again we have to come up with a common
denominator and what we really want to
do is find the least common multiple of
these two expressions and when I say
that let me let me just remind you let's
say we wanted to add let's say we wanted
to add one-fourth plus one-sixth well we
know that 1/4 1/4 is 1 over 2 times 2
and that 1/6 1/6 is 1 over 2 times 3 so
to be able to add these two things we
incrementally we both have a we both
have a common - we both have this common
- but in order for this guy to go into
whatever our common denominator is we're
going to have to be divisible by another
2 so let me do that so our common
denominators going to be we have this 2
in each of them so that takes care of
that first two but then we need the
second two we need the second two
they're two times a second - and then we
need this 3 here we need this 3 here we
have to have all of the prime factors of
both of them this has two 2's so this
guy has to have two 2's this guy has a 2
and a 3 so this guy has to have a 2 and
a 3 and so our least common multiple
here is 2 times 2 times 3 which is 12
and then we can add accordingly that is
our common denominator that's the least
common multiple you could have just
multiplied these two out but you've
gotten 24 and that's larger than
necessary you can still worked it out
but you would have more simplifying left
for you to do the same idea we can do
right here the same idea we can do here
we can factor both of these denominators
so x squared that is X plus 3 times X
minus 3 it's just a difference of
squares and x squared plus 5x plus 6
that is what that is X plus 2
times X plus 3 right 2 times 3 is 6 2
plus 3 is 5 so our common denominator is
going to be what what's going to be our
common denominator to clear up this real
estate over here
what's our common denominator going to
be our common denominator so this is
going to be equal to our common
denominator is going to be our common
denominator is going to have to have an
X plus 3 it's going to have to have an X
plus 3 in it so it's going to have to
have an X plus 3 in it and that takes
care of this X plus 3 as well it's going
to have an X minus 3 in it it's going to
have to have an X minus 3 in it so
that's an X minus 3 it's going to have
that X plus 2 in it X plus 2 in it
another way you could have thought about
it's like look it's going to have to
have all of the factors of this guy
which are X plus 3 times X minus 3 X
plus 3 times X minus 3 and it also has
to and then once you write those down
you say well it also has to have all the
factors for this guy well we already
have an X plus 3 there so we just have
to only add on the X plus 2 and that
saves us from multiplying both of these
expressions together this is the least
common denominator now if this is the
least common denominator what do we have
to change the one by well let me let me
actually rewrite this a little bit well
I'll write it like this so in order to
go what do you have to do to go from if
I start with 1 over x squared we write
it this way 1 over X plus 3 times X
minus 3 right this and this is the exact
same thing if I want an X plus 2 in the
denominator what do I have to do I have
to multiply the numerator and the
denominator by X plus 2 by X plus 2 so
this expression right here which is this
expression right here will become X plus
2 over X plus 3 times X minus 3 times X
plus 2 those would cancel out you're
just left with the one that's that right
there so this is the first term this is
the first term that is this term
this term over here the second term over
here this is 2 over 2 over X plus 2
times X plus 3
that's in its original form now if we
also want another if we want an X minus
3 here if we want an X minus 3
in the denominator we can multiply it by
X minus 3 over X minus 3 or essentially
we can multiply the numerator by X minus
3 so this is going to be equal to 2
times X minus 3 is 2x minus 6 over X
plus 2 times X plus 3 times X minus 3 so
this expression right here is the exact
same thing as this expression right over
here so if we were to add these two
expressions they have the same
denominator I just switch the order of
that I'm multiplying but they're the
exact same denominator which is exactly
the same thing as this so this this
first expression we're going to get our
X plus 2 here right X plus 2 over all of
this it would cancel and you get 1 over
X plus 3 times X minus 3 over 1 over X
my x squared minus 9 and then to that
you're going to add to that you're going
to add plus 2x minus 6 and why am i
adding 2x minus 6 because the second
term is 2x minus 6 over all of this
business because we're just multiplying
you could write this this would also be
written as 2 times X minus 3 over all of
this X minus 3s would cancel out and you
get this again so this is what we get
when we add the 2 and so this will be
equal to let me scroll down a little bit
this will be equal to X plus 2x is 3x 2
minus 6 is negative 4
all of that over this thing we can
either keep it multiplied out or we
factor it out or we could multiply it if
you like but I'll take some time to
multiply it so I'll just say X plus 3
times X minus 3 times X plus 2 and we
are done